E
CENTRAL PLAINS STATES.
MICHELLE?
>> ALL RIGHT.
THANK YOU.
>>> PRESIDENT BIDEN IS
ATTEMPTING TO TURN HIS WORDS AT
THE GLOBAL CLIMATE SUMMIT INTO
ACTION AFTER PLEDGING TO CUT
GREENHOUSE GAS EMISSIONS IN THE
U.S. BY MORE THAN 50% BY 2030.
THE EFFORT TO LOWER THE EARTH'S
TEMPERATURE THEORETICALLY PUTS
THE U.S. ON THE SAME PAGE AS
RUSSIA AND CHINA.
IT COMES AHEAD OF THE PRES
PRESIDENT'S FIRST JOINT ADDRESS
TO CONGRESS NEXT WEEK.
CHRISTINA RUFFINI HAS MORE FROM
THE WHITE HOUSE THIS MORNING.
GOOD MORNING, CHRISTINA.
>> Reporter: GOOD MORNING.
THE TWO-DAY GLOBAL VIRTUAL
SUMMIT WAS A RARE SHOW OF
SOLIDARITY BETWEEN WORLD LEADERS
WHO HAVEN'T EXACTLY BEEN THE
BEST OF FRIENDS, THERE WAS THAT
TENSE MEETING WITH THE CHINESE
IN ALASKA, MOSCOW AND WASHINGTON
HAVE BEEN EXPELLING EACH OTHER'S
DIPLOMATS, BUT THOSE ISSUES
DIDN'T COME UP.
LEADERS STUCK TO THE SCRIPT AND
TALKED ABOUT THE URGENT NEED TO
ADDRESS CLIMATE CHANGE.
>> WHEN WE INVEST IN CLIMATE
RESILIENCE AND INFRASTRUCTURE,
WE CREATE OPPORTUNITIES FOR
EVERYONE.
>> Reporter: IN WHAT WAS
ESSENTIALLY A GEOPOLITICAL ZOOM
SESSION --
>> I PLEDGE TO REDUCE ISRAEL'S
CARBON FOOTPRINT --
>> Reporter: THE LEADERS OF 40
COUNTRIES INCLUDING CHINA AND
RUSSIA PUT ASIDE SIMMERING
TRANSNATIONAL TENSIONS TO TALK
ABOUT CLIMATE CHANGE.
>> THE ENVIRONMENT CONCERNS THE
WELL-BEING OF PEOPLE IN ALL
COUNTRIES.
>> RUSSIA MAKES A GIGANTIC
CONTRIBUTION TO ABSORBING GLOBAL
EMISSIONS --
>> AS MUCH AS THE PRESIDENT OF
RUSSIA AND I DISAGREE, TWO BIG
NATIONS CAN COOPERATE TO GET
SOMETHING DONE.
>> Reporter: THE TWO-DAY VIRTUAL
SUMMIT WAS LONG ON SPEECHES AND
SHORT ON COMMITMENTS.
BUT THERE DID SEEM TO BE
AGREEMENT THAT GOOD
ENVIRONMENTALISM IS ALSO GOOD
FOR THE ECONOMY.
>> THIS IS NOT ALL ABOUT SOME
EXPENSIVE POLITICALLY CORRECT
GREEN ACT OF -- OF BUNNY
HUGGING.
IN IS ABOUT GROWTH AND JOBS.
>> Reporter: SOMETHING THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION SAYS IT ADDRESSES
IN ITS PROPOSED $2 TRILLION
INFRASTRUCTURE PLAN WHICH
INCLUDES MONEY FOR SOLAR, WIND,
AND OTHER RENEWABLE INDUSTRIES.
>> WE MUST ENSURE THAT WORKERS
WHO HAVE THRIVED IN YESTERDAY'S
AND TODAY'S INDUSTRIES HAVE AS
BRIGHT A TOMORROW IN THE NEW
INDUSTRIES.
>> Reporter: YESTERDAY THE
DEPARTMENT OF ENERGY ANNOUNCED
$100 MILLION PROGRAM TO HELP
COAL AND GAS WORKERS TO CUT
FOSSIL EMISSIONS BY 50% OVER THE
NEXT DECADE.
REPUBLICANS ARGUE A RAPID MOVE
AWAY FROM FOSSIL FUELS COULD
HARM THE COMMUNITIES THAT STILL
DEMAND ON THEM.
>> FOR IMPOSING COSTLY
ENVIRONMENTAL AGENDASES ON OUR
OWN ONE IS NOT SOMETHING OUR
BIGGEST FOREIGN COMPETITORS SEEM
TO SHARE.
>> Reporter: PRESIDENT BIDEN
WILL ADDRESS THOSE ISSUES AND
MORE IN A SPEECH TO A JOINT
SESSION OF CONGRESS NEXT WEEK.
HE'S HERE AT THE WHITE HOUSE
THIS MORNING BEFORE LEAVING FOR
HIS HOUSE IN DELAWARE.
FIRST, HE IS EXPECTED TO
DESIGNATE THE 1915 KILLING OF
ARM
ARMENIANS AS A GENOCIDE.
TURK